There aren't many people who are about my age. Basically,
I started by myself. I didn't have an environment to learn. After all,
the number of craftsmen has decreased so much.
Naturally, there is no school where you can learn properly
. It's Tezuka Psychology. 27-year-old
Amezaiku is edible.
The era is the Edo era. The
club era is 1600. The most popular candy crafts at home are
2 fish.
So-called 12th Neuko is something that has been a motif of candy work for a long
time, and at the time of shaping, if the time is fixed, it will harden in 5 minutes, so the
most important thing is still  It's a Sobu boat.
Anyway, you can read ahead and use it first. You can also use it.
Asakusa Amezaiku Amezaiku I run a new store.
I think that it is powerful because it is raining to the mark,
so
it is more important to think that it is important when asked if it is important in Japanese culture.  I think it's my job to
make things that are good for me. I think that it will become a tradition because things that evolve and are good for the times will remain,
so I really like that simple style.
I want to keep it because the style is attractive.